okay
so most of you already saw the flyer and
already filled out the forms to us
and we haven't of the names and
informations
um about uh you
and now like afterwards
you have to register for
to register for the courses and
it has to go through the louisiana state
university gene lab or the ilab
so this is um
this is the way that
so first thing is you have to have an
account
in the ilab
so most of the people like who are in
lsu or the lsu school of veterinary
science who have used the core facility
we you all have the account in the core
facility
however the people who are outside
louisiana state university
or maybe in the lbrn or somewhere else
uh you have to sign up for an account in
the ilab
so i will send you the link to sign up
after this orientation session i will
send out an email with the link
and we'll help you out how to create an
account here first
so some of the
students undergrad or
graduate students already reached out to
me and saying that they don't see their
pi's name in the system so for those of
you if you don't see your pi's name in
the list just send me an email and with
the informations of your pi's name and
email address and also the phone number
we will add your pi's name in the system
then you will be able to
register
so first after creating account you will
have to sign in
and then you will see a page like this
you will have your username and password
you will sign in and afterwards you will
see a page like this and you on the left
hand side
there will be
a tab called core facilities you have to
click on the core facilities
and then you have to select the serial
core facilities and services
and then on the right hand corner on top
corner you will see the request services
so this is one of the
services that the core facility does so
you will select the training modules
under the request services uh
tab
so once you get in there
you have to select the courses that you
want to take
so we already updated the name of the
courses for this semester so you will
see all these three names the
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
metagenomics and the big data analysis
uh on the left hand side and you will
select and if you have any specific
comments you can write in here
and then you can save this form and sit
like submit it later or you can directly
send it
and submit it with the
after introducing the fund number so
those of you who are part of the lbrn
program or part of lsu or school of
veterinary science
uh you can just write
that here and we
this course is free for you so we are
gonna put some numbers here and it will
be free for you however the people who
are outside louisiana state university
uh they have to put their phone number
where we should charge for the courses
and then
you just submit the request to to us
so then we will go through the overall
information here and then we'll accept
it and that is how your registration
will be completed so i will send out
this information in an email afterwards
after this orientation session and still
if you have any questions just send me
an email i'll be i'm physically like
here in the school of veterinary science
on the third floor
whoever in english you are in the web
school if you guys want to see me or
like have any specific questions you can
see me or you can send me an email
i will try to help you